sup everyone i am jordan remay and i am
joined by josh bast project director for
marvel's avengers thank you so much for
joining us today to talk about some new
marvel's avengers content
absolutely excited to be here thanks for
making time to speak with us as well
yeah of course now like right before
sitting down like
literally right before like 10 minutes
ago i got to see a new trailer for
some of the new content coming to
marvel's avengers
the new patrol the new cosmic cube
events the
new content coming in the wakanda
expansions lots of cool stuff i had to
mute myself so that i wouldn't embarrass
everyone in the discord call but i i
have
loads and loads of questions and
i really want to start with the cosmic
cube event specifically
um because this like new event seems
like very
geared towards like finally taking on
monica who's kind of been this thorn in
the avengers side for
a very long time um is
is this like a closing chapter for an
arc for
marvel's avengers uh because it feels
very final like we're finally going
after the big bad who's in charge of aim
who's kind of been around for a while
and
now we're finally going after her and it
feels like a sort of like end to aim
type of moment
yeah we absolutely showcased our
upcoming event cosmic cube event uh
which launches next week
uh and yeah in it we have our exciting
new villain sector as you said where
we'll face off against monica rappuccini
uh scientist supreme and sort of a
battle for control over
the cosmic cube which is pretty much an
ultimate
super weapon that she can use to bend
reality itself for her
her will and over through our heroes um
we're really excited about the story
that we're going to be telling there and
it's part of the
the narrative arc that will be continue
to move forward with our future beats
and roadmap
uh but we're partnering that on thursday
with a limited time
cosmic threat event will you be able to
partake in special missions and
challenges to earn
unique rewards and that event that
mission that we're getting is it sort of
like uh here's a little bit more story
kind of one and done
thing or is it a sort of event that like
you and your friends should be playing
over and over again to
grind up for some new rewards oh we
definitely want you to be playing this
both uh
if by yourself if you'd like but also
with your friends uh it'll be a
multiplayer
content and i think you'll definitely
enjoy it if you do so i'll say and
we got a first kind of first look at the
new
patrol that's kind of coming out that's
set in like the post-apocalypse
wasteland uh what type of missions are
people gonna be able to expect from that
new patrol
yeah like you said we're really excited
to provide that sneak peek and uh
wasteland patrols will come out uh later
this year and in it when players
selected from the war table
they'll enter a mission where they can
uh play against random encounters of
enemies and villains in a vast landscape
where there is no time restraint so they
can enjoy it i'm looking forward to
jumping back into some
marvel's avengers especially for and
like i think this
this might be where like most of my
excited squeals came from when you
all finally showcased black panther
and the story beats that are going to
come in the wakanda expansion i'm like
this looks so dope this looks so cool
i say it looks a little bit um a little
bit
mcu inspired in its uh
design uh what inspirations did you take
in designing
this uh t'challa this wakanda we
we definitely inspired directly from the
comics material uh from all the runs of
black panther and especially the
more recent uh rise of the black panther
run i say
i i'm pretty sure that was shuri like
his sister i'm like
it seems like her she's got that spunk
she's got that personality
but i'm like there's no subtitles i
can't tell like who the
speaker name is
yeah yeah in it we teased black panther
without his mask we definitely showed
shuri in the throne room
uh we also showed a koi and uh the rest
of the dora malay
uh we also teased uh ulysses claw the
main villain for this expansion and
in our story he's ultimately trying to
steal wakanda's vibramian it's up to you
playing as black panther with the rest
of the avengers and the rest of wakanda
to stop them i say i it was hard to like
get a gist of just
like how much there was just looking at
the trailers this something that's
similar in scope to what players have
seen already with the hawkeye and kate
bishop expansions is it a little bit
bigger is a little bit smaller
yeah i think that the the expansion is
is considerable in size to the the
past two operations that we've done both
between uh hawkeye
and uh kate bishop and we're excited
about
continuing offering uh additional
content on the monthly basis in which
we've been doing it
we see that continuing in the future
it's like i'm not sure
how much you can go into this but like
the fact that
like black panther he's he's not an
archer he's not like kate
and hawkeye like even though they had
very different skill sets both of them
had abilities and fighting powers that
were
very like geared around the fact that
they have a bow and arrow on their tool
set can you speak
to anything about how t'challa fits into
the overall
like squad makeup like what type of
character he is
well we'll definitely be covering that
more as we as we do our updates to our
road map
uh but what i can't say is it's been so
exciting uh playing as black panther the
the last few months uh on the
development project and just
you know celebrating the power of his
suit the wakandan technology
the ancestral past uh and
uh you know just uh it's it's it's it's
really a thing to watch uh his uh both
his traversal and his royal combat it's
it's gonna be really exciting
back to the cosmic uh cube event for
just a little bit um should players be
like expected to
grind out a little bit to prepare for it
is there like a minimum
level for it like what's the way of
getting into
fighting against monica
uh yeah i think it'll be content that's
available to all players to partake in
and we look forward to people jumping in
there and facing off against
monica i'll say it's definitely since
you're going up against monica it feels
like a
very campaign thing probably not
something you want to dive into
before you actually uh play the
story but should players
go through hawkeye and kate bishop's uh
campaign first before jumping into
the events of this upcoming event or
does it not connect too much to those
post-launch stories
oh absolutely i would definitely
recommend you know playing through the
single-player campaign
playing through kate bishop taking aim
playing through uh hawkeye future
imperfect it's just gonna make the
experience all the more richer
and yeah like read the comics uh look
for the inspirations
uh have fun while you play it uh and and
all of our stories i'm sure you're used
to
seeing the the quality that crystal
dynamics has been putting out uh
for the story of our games uh and this
is no exception and we
in every beat that we do is is still
intentionally moving
moving the bar forward i'll say and for
each
one of these uh things that we saw in
the trailer so we can go through them
one by one so the cosmic cube event the
new patrol the wakanda content like
what's the
overall goal for each of these things
like what
is the ideal for what each one of these
is supposed to bring to the marvel's
avengers
experience the way i could answer that
is is generally touching on
our generally our whole focus uh for
moving forward and
i think it's quite clear and if there's
one thing i wanted to say it's it's this
which is crystal dynamics is absolutely
dedicated to delivering the marvel's
avengers game
our fans want and deserve uh we aim to
deliver compelling content
uh you know we're talking about things
like iconic super villains iconic
locations from just the comics uh an
ever expanding
cast of heroes and and and partnering
that with meaningful rewards and
progression that our players want
deserve
i was saying you kind of detailed out
like a road map for this like we start
in june with the cosmic cube event like
people are going to be able to play the
first part of this trailer like
very soon is this kind of the
plan for the rest of 2021 or is this
kind of like oh here's like the next few
months but we have more in the pipeline
after this
well we definitely want to talk about
the roadmap as we update it and and
definitely celebrate that with the
community
uh and talk through those beats um i
think there'll be a little bit of
it's not necessarily that we have a
formula that we want to follow
uh but given the timing of e3 and the
cosmic cube event it made a lot of sense
to talk about here and we're really
excited about it uh but that's why we're
also taking the same opportunity to
really
speak up about just the same level of
excitement you have for black panther
you know we share that
um and so we'd love to talk about that
and and and through the course of the
summer we'll be updating our road map
and engaging in that conversation
it's like okay i i feel like i've done
my due diligence i feel like i've done
enough of going back to talk cosmic cube
and patrol that i can now selfishly
go back to asking you questions about
uh black panther um
i am i'll say i'm very curious like it's
one of those like
weird bizarre things that as we get into
more and more like
game as a service games like marvel's
avengers it's like oh you're gonna
attract like new players like
months years after the game has already
come out like is there any way for
someone to just
jump straight into the black panther
content if they're like oh i'm picking
up marvel's avengers
later this year like in the holidays or
something and i would like to just jump
immediately into this story just to see
it because i want to try it or
is it more like oh no this is this is
post
launch like you need to grind up to this
yeah we want people to
to participate in the content they're
really excited about and so yeah there's
no
uh rules or restrictions for a new
player jumping in and immediately
playing as black panther and
experiencing that uh those story
missions i was saying with
a few now story missions under the belt
like bishop hawkeye
the cosmic cube event is coming black
panther after that like
the story is like beginning to fill up
is there any plans to kind of do like uh
here's like a quick story recap if
you're like jumping in here it's like is
anything like that in the works or is it
more of a like the player kind of needs
to fill in the blanks
themselves yeah it's definitely
something we talk about internally in
the development development team
and uh we'll definitely share uh any
updates to that question as they come in
the roadmap
uh all right awesome that is all of my
questions for now that
don't like jump immediately into please
tell me like
every single detail of the story for a
black panther so that i
know what it is because it looks very
cool i'm excited to play
thank you josh so much for putting up
with my
geeky antics i i'm like
i'm like partially like shivering and
like excitement over here and i'm
really really hoping it doesn't come in
on the
video that i was like bouncing on my
chair in certain moments because that'll
look so unprofessional i'm so
embarrassed but that's
all the time we have thank you again so
much for joining me
and answering questions it's been fun
learning about what's coming in marvel's
avengers with the new patrol with the
cosmic cube event
with wakanda with black panther a lot of
exciting stuff a lot of things that i
think people have been still playing the
game
are going to be looking forward to and
for everyone at home who is watching
remember stay safe and stay tuned to
gamespot for
more marvel's avengers and play for all
content
see ya
you